Speaker 1: I want to talk about sort of
a media story that's been created out
of something that Joe Biden recently
said, which I agree with completely,
and I believe that it's being deliberately
misinterpreted. The other day, Joe Biden said
Putin can't remain in power. Putin can't
remain in power. And Joe Biden was correct.
And what Joe Biden obviously meant when
he said it was This guy's a disaster.
This guy is terrible for his own people. This guy
has invaded another country and is leading to the
deaths of I don't even want to say whether it's
thousands or tens of thousands or I mean, we just
don't know right now the amount of death that is
being caused by the Russian invasion of Ukraine.
And Joe Biden said this guy can't remain
in power. And Joe Biden was not saying,
we're going to invade Russia. Joe Biden was
not saying, we're going to assassinate Putin.
Joe Biden was not saying we're going to effect
regime change in Russia. He wasn't saying any of
those things. Now, has the U.S. done things like
that in the past? Of course, but it's not what
Joe Biden said. And it's very clearly not what Joe
Biden meant. I agree Putin can't remain in power,
but it's it's not up to us to take him out
of power. But Putin can't remain in power.
It would be better for the world, for Putin not
to be in power. It'd be better for the world,
for Rodrigo do territory not to be in power. It'd
be better for Kim Jong UN not to be in power.
Bolsonaro, Maduro. I mean, there's
lots of leaders where I would say
this guy can't remain in power. This is not
good. But that's different than we're going
to take them out or U.S. imperialism is going to
effect regime change or any of those things. Well,
yesterday Joe Biden did an event where he
announced his new budget and billionaire
tax that we spoke about on the bonus show. He
took about 10 or 11 questions from reporters,
and almost all of them were versions of the
same question. Wasn't it wrong for you to
suggest you're going to take Putin out? And of
course, that's not what Joe Biden said. So let's
look at some of these examples, and this is a
perfect example of I know that these reporters
understand that's not what Joe Biden meant. Joe
Biden didn't say, I want to invade Russia. I want
to remove Putin. I want to assassinate Putin or
any of these things. Joe Biden just said this
guy can't remain in power for the good of the
world, and I even lost my headphones because I'm
gesticulating so wildly. So let's start with the
first one here. Here is Kelly O'Donnell from NBC.
Speaker 2: Kelly O'Donnell NBC.
Speaker 3: Thank you, Mr. President.
Do you believe what you said? Thank you, sir.
Do you believe what you said that Putin can't
remain in power? Or do you now regret saying that
because your government has been trying to walk
that back? Did your words complicate matters?
Speaker 2: Well, yes. Three different questions.
I'll answer them all. Number one, I'm not walking
anything back. The fact of the matter is I was
expressing the more outrage I felt toward the
way Putin is dealing in the actions of this man,
which is just brutality. You have two children
in Ukraine. I just come from being with those
families. And and so but I want to make it clear
I wasn't then, nor am I now articulating a policy
change. I was expressing moral outrage that I
feel I make no apologies for. It's personal,
my personal feelings. Secondly, you asked
me about, well, what was the second part?
Speaker 3: Locate the diplomacy of this moment.
Speaker 2: No, I don't think it does. You know,
the the fact is that we're in a situation where
it complicates the situation, as the moment is the
the escalatory efforts of Putin to continue and
engage in carnage, the kind of behavior that
that makes the whole world say, Mike. All right.
Speaker 1: So I think you get the point.
He's not saying there's a new policy is not
saying we're invading Russia. He's not saying
any of those things. You just say this. This
guy can't remain in power. And this is really
one of those cases where media is seizing on
something and there's really nothing there. Next,
we'll go to Peter Doocy from Fox, who, by the
way, for for all of the ad. For surreal questions
that Peter Doocy asks, Joe Biden keeps
calling on him at almost every press avail.
Let's listen. Thank you. Thank you very much.
Speaker 2: I know you're going to ask a really
nice question. Well, it's it's
an important question, I think.
Are you worried that other leaders in the world
are going to start to doubt that America is
back? If some of these big things that you say
on the world stage keep getting walked back,
then it might get him walk back made it
sound like just the last couple of days
it sounded like he told U.S. troops they were
going to Ukraine. It sounded like he said it was
possible the U.S. would use a chemical weapon, and
it sounded like you were calling for regime change
in Russia. And we know not only three
occurred, none of the three, none of
the three. Mr. President, you interpret the
language that way. I was talking to the troops.
We're talking about helping train the troops
and that are the Ukrainian troops that are in
Poland. That's the context. I sat there
with those guys for a couple of hours.
That's what we talked about. So when you
said you're going to see when you were there,
you were not intending. I was referring to with
be with and talking with the Ukrainian troops here
in Poland. And when you said a chemical weapon
use by Russia would trigger a response in time,
it will trigger a significant response. What does
that mean? I'm not going to tell you, why would
I tell you you're going to be showing the world?
Speaker 1: OK, so that's on the first two points.
And then Biden again going on to address this
question of regime change, regime change,
you were calling for regime change. And of course,
he was not an every reporter asking this. They
it's like they they smelled blood in the
water and they could ask nothing else.
Speaker 3: Back to your original words that he
cannot remain in power. Can you help us understand
you have more foreign policy experience than any
president who's ever held this office, right?
Whether those are your personal feelings or your
feelings as president, you understand why people
would believe you as someone commanding one of
the largest nuclear arsenals in the world, saying
someone cannot remain in power is a statement of
U.S. policy. And also, are you concerned about
propaganda use of those remarks by the Russians?
Speaker 2: No and no.
Speaker 3: Tell me why you have so
much experience. You are the leader
of this country as this ridiculous.
Speaker 2: Nobody believes we're
going to take down. I was going to I
was talking about taking down Putin.
Nobody believes that. No one.
Speaker 1: No. And I think he's
right that even these reporters don't believe
it. I don't think these reporters really believe
Biden was saying, we're going to go in and take
Putin out and do regime change. He just said,
this guy can't stay in power.
Speaker 2: What have I been talking about
all since this all began? The only war that's
worse than one intended is one that's unintended.
The last thing I want to do is engage in
a land war or a nuclear war with Russia.
That's not part of it. I was expressing
my outrage at the behavior of this man.
Speaker 1: All right. So you guys get it. And
this is the perfect story of the media driven
narrative. When Joe Biden said this had reporters
not started going crazy saying, All right, sir,
are you demanding regime change? It never
would have become a story. There's plenty
to criticize Joe Biden about. This is not it,
and it's almost a signal as to I mean, listen,
it wasn't even a slow Newsweek. And yet still
seven out of the 10 questions or something,
we're focused on this very strange stuff and not
particularly informative to the American public.